Hey guys welcome back! So last week I posted a
video of the famous tremolo piece Recuerdos de la
Alhambra and so many of you reached out asking to
see if I would do a video talking about how I play
tremolo... so here we are! This video will be in
two parts. If you are a guitarist who can't play
tremolo but who wants to learn, this video is for
you and if you're a more advanced guitar player
but you want to learn how to improve your tremolo
technique, next week there will be a part two justfor you, so stay tuned.
So tremolo on the guitar
is like a magic trick it creates the illusion thatthere are two instruments playing at the same
time and the way it works is that basically
the thumb plays its own part like this. A simplearpeggiation and then that's gonna keep on going
but then we're gonna add the fingers rapidly
plugging in between each thumb stroke like this
and it creates the most beautiful haunting
murmuring melody in the background
so to break that down further, between every thumb
stroke we have to fit in these three fingers in
this order ring middle index so tremolo is when
we play thumb ring middle index thumb ring middle
index on repeat.  Now in classical guitar lingowe give the fingers special names this is P I Mand A
So Pema Pima whatever you want to call it
but for the rest of the video I'll be referringto the fingers by those terms.
Okay so to learnthis technique let's start by putting all of
our fingers in our right hand except the pinky onthe first string, that's the high E string and make
sure when you do this that your thumb actually
goes to the left of the fingers so it's not inside
the hand hidden it's to the left of the fingers
from your point of view. Also the wrist shouldn't
be bent in like this.  Sometimes guitarists like torest their palm on the bridge or the wood this is
no good.  We want to keep the wrist relativelystraight some light natural bend is is okay so
all four fingers on the first string, thumb to theleft, straight wrist, and now we can start P A M I PA M I.
That's the basic tremolo technique.
Okay now once you practice this a bit, we
can get ready for our first exercise
it'sall about planting the fingers early on thestring so after you play P, the thumb, the ring
finger is going to land instantly down on the
string which will stop it early and then when
we play the ring finger that middle finger
M is gonna land early, then the middle finger
plays and the index lands early so all the
fingers land early which stops the strings
and makes it sound staccato. Staccato simplymeans detached in Italian so here we go playing
staccato tremolo at 60 BPM and while you do
this try to keep your hands still.
We don'twant to play with the hands. We don't want toplay with the arm. Keep the hand nice and still
And next we can alternate that staccato
exercise with a legato exercise.  Legato
being the opposite of staccato if
staccato means detached, legato means
there's no gap between the notes they
are connected like so. That's legato.
So now we can go back and forth between the
two.  Once staccato, once legato.  Ready go
keep the hands still remember.
Okay the nextexercise is all about learning to controlthe amount of force that each finger exertson the string and the way we're going to dothat
is by practicing accenting one finger at
a time.  So let's turn a metronome on at 80 bpm
and we'll start by accenting P, the thumb. Ready, and PAMI, PAMI
and this turns out to be pretty easy because
the thumb is naturally louder than the fingersbut next let's go to the A finger. So we have P A M I.
Next we'll do M.
Try to be with the metronome
okay let's move to the index finger I.
and lastly, we're gonna go for a completely eventremolo.  This is surprisingly difficult. One finger
inevitably wants to pop out so spend some
good time here and see if you can make themreally all sound the same.
Okay so now that your
tremolo is working let's go to the next level
we want to start letting the thumb skip around
between different strings while the fingers stay
on the first string doing tremolo.  This is whatcreates the illusion of two instruments playingat the same time.
So what we're going to do is
we'll start with all four fingers on the first
string and then one by one, the thumb will jump
to the second string, third string, fourth, all the
way to the sixth string E, and then back up. Forthis let's turn our metronomes on to 110 bpm
Readygo!
Remembering to keep your thumb to the left
Flat wrist.  Okay now let's just have some funwith this.  If you just hold down a basic chord
like A minor the left hand just leave those
fingers there and we're just going to
basically do the exercise we just did but your thumb
can skip around at random.  It sounds like this:
Instantly beautiful and if you want to even goto the next level we can add a chord progression.
to left hand let's try a minor D minor E
major we'll finish back on a minor here we go
Okay last thing for the day: Let's learn
a little Spanish tune called Malagueña.
The whole thing is going to be played
with the thumb and it sounds like this:
And that's just going to repeat.  Play this
until you can do it perfectly every singletime
because next we're gonna add
tremolo between each thumb stroke.
And then you can go faster
Now go spend 10 minutes a day working on these
three exercises just like we did today with themetronome.
And in a week or so you'll already
be able to start incorporating this magicaltechnique
into your playing and remember if
you're a more advanced player and want to go
deeper, part two is next week we'll be talking
all about more advanced tremolo techniques.
But for now, thank you for watching! Please subscribe
if you haven't already. Also you can consider
supporting myPatreon if you want to help memake more videos in the future.  See you next time!